a few terms that the media might need to
know a semi-automatic weapon is not an
automatic weapon there is also known as
CNN there's no such thing as a full
semi-automatic weapon semi-automatic
weapon for those you don't know
everybody in the audience knows does
we're Nebraska right we're not in
California where I live
[Applause]
note to all of the anchors at CNN a
semi-automatic weapon is a weapon that
fires once when you pull the trigger
once and chambers around and that's all
a semi-automatic weapon is an automatic
weapon is you hold the trigger down and
lots of bullets fire this is not
difficult
stop misusing the terms you sound stupid
when people say assault rifle an assault
rifle generally means a machine gun
these have been illegal in the United
States essentially since 1986
okay assault weapon is a term that means
nothing assault weapon is a bizarre
legal term of art that base that means
that you add a couple of features to a
normal rifle so you can have a rifle
that looks not scary and it's not an
assault weapon and you paint it black
and you had a pistol grip and sub lates
an assault weapon which is why the
assault weapons ban of 1994 made no
sense and had no impact on gun violence
in the United States a silencers that
bunch people who are arguing that
silencers are super dangerous and acting
like silencers do what they do in the
movies where it sounds like every time
you fire a bullet okay that's not what a
silencer does it is still just as loud
as a jackhammer